lastly lastly does anyone have an
explanation for why when I put negative
one into a baby Kings boma
anyone got a suggestion for me yeah okay
I could suggest that anybody have to be
positive that would be a bit of a
problem for me because so far on the
board I've written this and I've said
that it's correct and that would be a
real problem for us if it weren't okay
now you might say oh well maybe one can
be negative and one comes which of
course begs the question why like who
made that up like you know oh we decided
this should be seven on the side and
engaged in math last 45 minutes and you
can move me have whatever men you write
like you make that up the real question
is who even decided it's do any of you
even know why it works in the first
place because the teacher told you cuz
you're starting your textbook because it
allows you to get the answer right on
the test
isn't it a lesson to you by the way
before I show you why this is the case
before I show you why it ends up with a
paradox please don't ever do that I know
you as a mathematician myself I've done
it for years I've accepted rules and not
known why they worked if you accept
rules and not know why they work you're
not the mathematician you're a machine
and you're not here to become machines
right there are machines that then you
if what you try to do is a bit P machine
when you see a rule don't accept it like
it's there for a reason
work it out I will tell you why you want
to pay very close attention why do we
say that the square you may be is the
square root of eight times the square
root of thing well just have a look at
us doing these square roots over here
the whole point are saying that
something equals something else is that
if you have a look at the left and you
have a good right
do the same things to both sides and get
the same thing out do you agree that was
the whole point of doing all of this to
get to here because if you square those
you get that okay now the reason why we
say is is because if you take the square
root of a B right let's say what is that
number okay well I don't know what it is
let's just give it a name let's call X
and then you say well what about root
Avery could be separately right what is
that well imagine you're in a universe
where you don't know that these things
are the same right
well we'll call that and give it a none
there what can we do with these things
to see what the relationship with these
news okay now you've been doing this for
a while for example if I told you hey
here's a number and here is another
number and I say hey is this some
relationship between these two things
right you'd say well I guess what I'd
have to do is kind of like eliminate
something over here so I could get these
guys talking to each other do you agree
okay now you can have to do the same
thing here it's all simple though and
with parametric's what can you do to
these things to make them turn you can
square them right okay you square x
squared so are you square X right that's
going to give you don't go to skip
anything here that's that right well if
it's the square root of a B you better
get back Amy do you remove that but this
now because you're so good at your index
laws and your serves you saw almost jump
to the answer that don't because that's
the whole reason why this works or why
it doesn't work this is the square root
of a square root of B Square this is not
just a simple right where you've got two
things of product being square what
happens at the end
you've got to swear both of the
factories don't you right so this is in
fact root a square and root B Square do
you agree with that that makes sense
okay but look look now you see oh well
but that's a and that's been right so
what's a fair conclusion enemies are x
and y the same number
well it could be if it's perfectly
reasonable that is a possibility but
it's not the only possibility because
you squared them right you squared to
make them talk and you know that x and y
aren't necessarily the same number how
do I show that no I you guys know you
shouldn't divide through when you see
something like this right you should
actually move this guy over here and
then you should or surprise surprise you
should factorize right so then you
notice wait a second there's the not one
solution to this there are two you can
suspicious yeah right X is not just it
doesn't just have to be wine right it
can be minus y as well right and in fact
if you go ahead you can actually graph
this thing on the complex plane when a
and B are negative when they're both
negative which is what we were in
Kentucky before you don't take the
positive one you must take the negative
one right because both solutions about
it just depends on waivers